[Music]
it's been a wild few weeks in the world
of news and by popular demand you've won
up the phone's begging us to bring back
final examine so think we have we're
pitting the professionals against each
other as we always do to see who has
kept the closest track of the weird
things that have happened the past week
the winner awarded prizes from the
tucker carlson comstor this week's first
contestant is Trump campaign legal
adviser Jenna Ellis she's on this show
quite a bit tonight she's making your
final exam debut she's facing off
against guy Benson close to the guy
Benson show on Fox News Radio thanks to
you both for coming on I hope you're a
little bit nervous always we are total
but you know it's a privilege just to be
nominated
good please thank the little people who
made it possible
alright solutely you know the rules I
know you've been studying but in case
you missed them here they are hands on
buzzers I ask the questions the first
one to buzz in gets to answer you have
to wait and this is critical until I
finish asking until you answer I can
answer once I acknowledge II by saying
her name every correct answer is worth
one point you get it wrong we take a
point away first to five wins ready
ready
all right this is question one now we
were asked by the national game show
Commission in Billings Montana to begin
with a question about food and so of
course we are it's a multiple choice
okay it's about Dunkin Donuts it was
just revealed that a new donut is
entering the market with a brand new
glaze on it is that glaze a hot sauce B
barbecue sauce or C spicy mustard guy
Benson I'm gonna go with barbecue
barbecue that's that's a sensible answer
is it right here we go
and finally this same with food Dunkin
Donuts revealing the hottest donut of
the year they're serving with red hot
sauce to release a hot sauce jelly donut
OMG being sensible tucker that's a very
deep point not in 2020 it doesn't see we
do better on question two is again a
multiple choice to wait for all the
options please which presidential
candidate famous for talking about
climate change in the most concerned
was spotted looking appropriately
sheepish getting off a private jet
recently was it a Bernie Sanders be
Elizabeth Warren C Tom Steyer I'm gonna
ask the judges tell me who got to the
first two that Jen Ellis yes it was
Elizabeth Warren and she should have
what she wish she wasn't warned and she
should have looked sheepish is Jenna
correct
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
she looks very she doesn't look proud
she's not taking a selfie to put on
Instagram in front of g4 why is that
kind of weird all right question three
nice job this is a very tough one so
it's gonna be another multiple choice
here it is sunday was Groundhog Day
February 2nd and we're reminded of the
2014 tragedy in which New York City
Mayor and known incompetent Mayor Bill
de Blasio dropped Staten Island Chuck
sadly the groundhog died after hitting
the ground we learned the groundhog
wasn't actually called Chuck I know why
we called him Chuck poor Chuck what was
his real name was it a Charlotte was it
B Brooklyn was it C Gabi I got nothing
okay she was you just for me to lose a
point yes I do yes I'm not falling for
that guy what happens if we don't want
to I'm gonna count to three how about
this well sweeten the pot see our judges
obvious you're gonna be guessing we'll
make it a two point question you get two
points if you get it right and we won't
subtract a point if you get it wrong
okay then I'll buzz in for that and try
okay
I will say it's B Brooklyn B Brooklyn
okay
rotating please is a Brooklyn another
borough this footage from Groundhog Day
2014 shows freshly inaugurated Mayor
Bill de Blasio appearing to drop Staten
Island Chuck about a week later the
animal died and only now are the
circumstances of its death starting to
emerge and also coming to light is this
Staten Island Chuck was actually Staten
Island Charlotte a female stand-in
unfortunately that is not correct but we
are not subtracting a point because
you're brave enough to guess we want to
encourage wild guessing on the show okay
so here we are to question four and this
is not a multiple choice which 2020
candidate says he is a strict policy of
never calling people on their birthdays
I would never call people on their
birthday it sounds like the president
honestly no it's it's a candidate yeah
candidate but I never side like me like
so so you're encouraging wild guessing
right so I never I never call people on
their birthdays it's not hard I never
call people on their birthdays that's a
straightforward question he's over seven
I don't know the answer
oh they're all over 70 fine oh all right
what what's the guess I will go with Joe
Biden was it Joe Biden
what are you likely to fail at or to do
poorly as president
look I don't tolerate but terribly well
I'm not good at pleasantries if you have
your birthday I'm not gonna call you up
to congratulate you so you'll love me
and you're right nice things about me
that's not what I do I should have gone
with the grumpier right yeah I mean
Biden's the kind of guy who would debt
you know what he'd probably forget it
was your birthday but if he remembered
he would call you all right rub this is
easy cuz with zero zero going into the
plan I know
it's a multiple choice you may have been
one of the millions of people who
watched the Super Bowl ratings were up
for the first time in five years how
many people tuned in to the Super Bowl
this year these are tough questions but
you have three options okay and don't
hesitate if you got a sense go for it
was it a 88 million was it be 102
million was it see a hundred and fifty
five million people died B it was B was
it B to the tape Sunday's Super Bowl
brought in huge numbers for Fox
we were the network that ran it how many
watched 102 million viewers watch the
Chiefs win over the 49ers one of the
10th most-watched ever oh and you are
right
did you know is that a guess - I know I
knew and I'm just glad I didn't blow the
Fox trivia question that may not play
well up in New York with our bosses so
I'm relieved that I got it right right
it was in your morning information
packet was yes thank you congratulations
to you Jenna good job you're an
excellent guess or an enthusiastic one
and that counts on this show though not
graduation congratulations